the more successful I got the more
miserable I became you start to get
accolades and affirmation for how well
you're doing hey you're doing a great
job keep doing what you're doing but I
don't like to do what but keep doing it
there's a seminal moment and which I was
a big ass VC I had a portfolio company
in San Francisco and I had to fly across
the country and fire the CEO and fly all
the way back cuz that's what you were
expected to do and I got into the house
after this incredibly exhausting day my
daughter who was then 3 years old was at
the top of the stairs I looked up at her
I spun around as I was collapsing and
going down hitting my head on the
bathroom door I heard her say mommy
mommy daddy died and I said to myself
what the am I doing that was the
beginning of what took about a year and
a half of realization that this was not
the life that I was meant to live